hey guys this is andrew from
tradingsensors.com i'm a professional
trader and i've been working for several
big investment banks like hsbc or
commerce bank in the past five years in
hong kong
and i just started to make some youtube
videos where i mostly talk about
technical analysis and i try to give you
guys
all the information that i have all the
experience to share with you my
experience
about how i use it at work and stuff
like this
so today i want to talk about uh the
bitcoin rally and see
where this is going let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so let's just quickly
make an overview of the bitcoin so this
is 218 this is 221 so you have
three years here so for those who
watched already in my previous videos
i was saying that here of course it was
a very nice level to buy this was ten
thousand we went to the 20 000 level
i was of course bullish all this uh
build up
period and we went through it
very brutally we broke the resistance
level and now we're trading higher all
right
so the question is where are we heading
so to get
my targets i measure so i do it again i
use fibonacci for those who
haven't seen what i do so basically
fibonacci is about
measuring the previous wave so here is
this one
okay i go to here and you apply the move
to the bottom of the wave that is
happening right now all right and then
you have the fibonacci levels they're
going to be
some selling levels so 35 000 is one of
them
i was saying here that uh i was a seller
at 35 000 and that probably we're gonna
have some consolidation that would last
about two to three weeks
this is exactly what i said in my
previous videos you can go check it out
this is what i was telling to my friends
that uh you know a lot of them they have
bitcoin they're calling me like hey
you're bro can you give me
some advice what would you do in this
situation uh what do you think this
market is doing
and i i'm trying to help but of course i
i don't know
what i know uh for sure is that there is
a high probability that the
fibonacci retracement ratios are gonna
act as
resistance so here we had one it worked
perfectly
let's zoom in a little bit so this is
what happened recently so i was saying
here it's all the new institutional
clients that are just buying this
uh this bitcoin and the question is now
are we going to revert or are we going
to go higher so i was saying in my
previous videos that i see
maybe a pullback to the 20 area it went
to 23
000 uh so maybe maybe this is done maybe
the pullback is finished
and what i see here let me be honest
with you guys i see something very
bullish
all right i see something very very
bullish
and this to me looks actually i mean it
is a triangle and usually triangles
there are continuation pattern moves
means that you usually have a breakout
in the direction of the
larger degree wave here the larger
degree wave is this one
and uh i expect here to have a break
a breakout on the upside of course there
is no guarantee of this
so you can for example i just told this
to one of my friends maybe he recognized
himself
a few minutes ago i told him bro you can
buy at 33
22 so you have this triangle pattern let
me show you guys on the four hours time
frame it's even more clear
i told him you can buy around 33 32 this
area
and you put a stop loss around 30 1 32
or maybe i said 33 334
so this area and you put the status
around 31.32 somewhere here but once
again be careful we stop those guys on
bitcoin because this market is so wide
that you can have some fake breakouts
just like you did here
all right so careful with stop losses so
here for example
the trade i would uh i would do
i would buy around here so i would have
like five percent uh drawdown
uh maximum loss and what is the next
level that we're heading to
if we break it all right it's the next
fib retracement
so it's the next few retracement is 50
lower guys so you can lose five you can
make 15
1 to 10 risk ratio this is a beautiful
trend
so if you believe in the bitcoin just
you know you can
do this one once again for those who
haven't watched the video where i
explain how to train the breakout
i'm gonna show you very quickly here but
please go to see this video it's like i
did like one week ago something like
this
break out trading secrets basically you
need to select the right time frame
so here for example i think that this
time frame might be a little bit
too short but you need to wait for
confirmation so confirmation would be
when you have two consecutive candles
that are below the support level or
above the resistance level
but here to be honest it's the bitcoin i
would rather do this
i would use a daily time frame and to me
there wouldn't be
any confirmation unless we have two
consecutive days for example above
36 000 so at least 24 hours full
the bitcoin is trading above 36 000.
this to me is a very bullish
signal and don't buy the breakout as i
said you need to buy the consolidation
the build up so you need to buy
here you're not buying here here you can
stop your position or you wait for a
re-test but guys if this breaks up on
the assigned
you won't have time to buy a retest so
you need to buy
at lower level not at higher levels all
right
very quickly i want to go to the news
because it's interesting to notice
that actually when you tap type bitcoin
on the internet
usually you have all the very good news
coming i just did it
like five minutes ago i typed bitcoin
news first thing i see is jonathan
suggests curtailing cryptocurrencies
such as bitcoin saying there are mainly
used for legal financing
guys this is not good all right because
this dirty money because there is a lot
of dirty money in the bitcoins we know
that
uh is actually now under scrutiny by the
regulators
so this is not good news guys just to
make it like in line with what i was
saying
maybe we're gonna have a final move up
this looks like a final move up so
technically this is bullish
uh even if we don't have the breakout
yet but ultimately
we have a lot of bad news that are
happening right now
that's why you need to use a stop loss
and i think that after 55 000 which is
the next
fib extension level we're gonna have a
deeper correction because you have this
bad news coming so the option market
i'm an option trader so i know what it
is about the bitcoin option option
market
is getting much bigger and you have 3.7
billion us dollars
of options uh that are set to expire so
i'm not sure this is a premium
or notional but what i know probably
guys bought some color options you know
of course because this is the bitcoin so
they buy calls uh the calls are gonna
expire so what is gonna happen
means some long positions are gonna
disappear so it's like if someone was
selling and now do you think that those
guys that made a lot of money
uh here do you think they're gonna rule
the position by the equivalent amount of
bitcoin that they had
maybe not so you know this expiry that
happens uh the 29th
of january this is going to create a lot
of uh
selling pressure and not sure we're
going to have the buying pressure that
is coming
but once again i hear around me that a
lot of people want to buy the bitcoin at
this level and the target 55
60 maybe 100 so you know all this
uh together is telling me the bulls are
still in control of this market
i think it's gonna go higher but be very
careful and
55 000 is probably gonna be the level
where we're gonna have a deeper
correction
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click the like
sub and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i see you guys